The thing on the top left here: a Taktia router.
These guys from MIT. They made a handheld router
that's a little robotic computer-controlled router.
So it's a little handheld router
like you'd use in woodworking.
But the router itself can move a couple inches
back and forth within the little case that you hold.
It's got a little camera on it
it's got a little screen. And what it does
is you can actually say I want to
cut a straight line from here to here.
And as long as you keep the dot in the circle
it will adjust the
router to take all your jaggy motions out. And just cut
a perfectly straight line. Or I want
to cut a star shape out
and I don't have the skill to actually do that by hand.
But the machine will totally help you do
the fine motor control to make that work.
So I think we're going to see a
lot more stuff like that. Where it's not
about making some machine like we have.
Like we have a giant robot that does the
exact same thing. And I don't have
to keep a dot in a circle or anything.
I program it, tell it what to do, walk away.
It cuts stuff while I'm off working.
But in this instance anybody can
pick that up and use it. You don't have to
program it, you don't have to know CAD...
That kind of semi-automated approach
is just huge.
A great thing on the top right there, too, is
people working alongside robots.
So a robot arm like this one,
that's carving out foam, it will kill you.
If you stand next to it. If it swings over
while you're working next to it will...
it will cause a lot of damage to you.
They're big. They're heavy. They're very
powerful. So this thing has to be in a
cage by OSHA rules. And you can't go
anywhere near it when it's working.
But that robot up there at the top,
that's a special robot that this new company
called Universal Robotics is making.
It's all belt-driven internally.
If that robot arm hits you it doesn't hurt you at all.
It just hits you and that's it. It has a slip belt system
on the inside. So if it hits something
it doesn't do any damage.
It just stops.
So that arm is what's loading
and unloading that CNC mill
that that machinist is working at.
So instead of the machinist wasting his time
loading and unloading the mill, the
robot arm loads and unloads the mill.
And that guy can do higher value tasks.
So semi-automated. I'm not trying to
make it to where nobody's ever needed.
But I'm keeping a human in the loop
because humans are awesome and they do great jobs.
But at the same time I'm working
side-by-side with them.
The other thing is that--a friend of ours
that does big massive sculptures, he did the
bow and arrow on the waterfront here in
San Francisco. His name is Bill Chrysler, he's
a really awesome guy. He has a CNC
machine the size of a basketball court.
It wouldn't fit in this room. It's a
five-axis machine. He bought it from
a boat builder its massive. Massive thing.
For a lot of their projects, when they're
doing complicated sculptural work,
they'll actually have the CNC router
only get it about 80% of the way there.
And then their talented crew of sculptors
comes in and finishes the 20% by hand.
Because it's faster. It's that 80/20 rule.
The machine can do 80%
of the work in 20% of the
time. And then that last little bit of
finishing work is done by hand because
that's where the artistry and the craft
really come into it to make the piece really
good. Like if you tried to make it to
where it came off the CNC machine 100% done
you're going to spend a 100x the amount of time
in programming the CNC machine. And it
still might not look as good.
Because it didn't have that final touch that a
a talented sculptor's able to do.
Lastly, you know, this is a protein folding
diagram. One of the cool things is when
you start to make things with robots
is you can make things--the joke that we
say is--you can make things that want
to be built. So if you put all the parts in a box
and you shook the box long enough
you'd wind up with the assembled cabinet
like what's under the stairs over here.
It's a theoretical idea, but basically we can
make it so that stuff only goes
together the right way. So again it's
semi-automated. I'm not trying to make a
machine that will assemble cabinets for me.
Instead I'm making really smart parts
that are really simple for anybody to
put together to make a cabinet.
So everything's kind of IKEA-like or something.
And nature is a great example of that.